[Musique]
depuis 14 ans cet ancien cinéma est
devenu une salle de spectacle
incontournable de la réunion une
diversité et un dynamisme soutenu par le
conseil départemental
ce discret dans ses attendus ces
régionales monsieur le maire du port et
voilà l'originalité de ce lieu de
spectacle un grand nombre d'institutions
contribuer au fonctionnement et à chaque
fois sur une durée de quatre ans que
c'est un projet qui s'appuie sur un
certain nombre de valeurs
je pourrais pas les citer tous mais
évidemment on va y retrouver l'ouverture
le partage la solidarité à référencer
contexte économique des fois de plus en
plus contraints ce département est très
attaché à tout ce qui va être fait en
lien avec la population sur les
territoires à tout ce qu'on va pouvoir
faire aussi avec les collèges il ya
beaucoup de projets toute l'année et
donc évidemment et puis tout ce qui est
créé et soutient la création musicale en
général réunionnaise c'est quelque chose
qui tient à coeur au département et donc
il nous accompagne sur le projet
notamment pour ses accès spécifique la
la valorisation du territoire et des
gens est clairement un des axes majeurs
pour le département qui accompagne cette
offre culturelle avec 55 mille euros de
subventions
d'un bel outil qui répond à un de nos
objectifs majeurs
c'est le lien social le bien vivre
ensemble et quand on sait que les
artistes qui travaillent ici avec à
bordeaux vont au devant de la population
pour travailler notamment en bas
d'immeuble avec les jeunes les moins
jeunes à conçoit des spectacles avec eux
eh bien c'est ce fameux vivre ensemble
qui se consolide à travers les actions
du kabardock ici au port les axes de
développement du cahier des charges sont
ambitieux mais comme toujours c'est la
fréquentation du lieu qui déterminera le
succès de cette mission de service au
public
[Musique]